starting this our office Kim in Dallas
hi Kim welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up well my parents are in
their late 60s and my mom is about to
retire my dad is only getting social
security right now and my mom said that
she's about to get her tsp and she said
her income will be only about two
thousand a month after she retires and
my parents are kind of wanting the kids
are four of us to kind of help them in
their retirement and we don't really
know what to do okay
well the first thing I do when I help
anyone is I want to know how long the
help is going to have to be there how
much the help is and why if you're
asking for my money you're also asking
for my interference into your life okay
and so we're going to do a budget mom
and we're gonna look at your Social
Security income and that Social Security
income and we're gonna look at your TSP
how much is it and what's it invested in
and why is it only creating $2,000 a
month maybe we need to move it to a
smart Wester Pro get it better invested
it'll create $3,000 a month okay you get
to take my advice if you take my money
you don't get one without the other
okay so then when we lay all of that out
if there is still a need then you look
at it and you go well I mean there's not
a need if we sell your stupid $50,000
car you know I don't know if they got a
$50,000 car but you see what I'm saying
when you look at it and you go okay I'm
willing to participate here but if I'm
writing checks you're gonna be on an
austere budget I'm not writing checks
for you to live the life of luxury
because you didn't save money okay
is that fair that's very fair so you do
not have a moral obligation to give your
parents money but I do have an emotional
obligation to investigate should I and
under what circumstances should I and
you know if you figure out $1,000 a
month really really makes their life a
considerable amount better they can
actually stay in the current home and
they they have a little bit of wiggle
room in their budget and each of you
want to chip in two or $50 a month
until they die then we're going to do
that but we're gonna be living on a
budget we're going to investigate your
expenditures we're going to investigate
your investments and we're going to get
all of it working very efficiently for
you and then whatever that all that
won't cover then we'll talk about
chipping in
but chipping in blindly no not a chance
right okay that makes sense because you
might be adding to a problem rather than
being a blessing okay you could be
buying a drunk a drink is what I'm
saying yeah we don't know till we dig
into it so I'm always amazed at what I
find when I dig into these things that
people panic with knowing only a few of
the numbers when we put all the numbers
together all the panic starts to go away
and I think that's where you are so hey
it's cool that you guys are willing to
do that but it's going to involve some
time actually really good generosity
takes more time than sloppy generosity
sloppy tea generosity as I respond to
somebody's guilt trip or society's guilt
trip but I just throw money at something
and walk away and I don't think about
the results of it that's sloppy
generosity it's still generosity you're
still giving money to someone that
purportedly needs it but real generosity
involves due diligence and getting
involved in being a blessing and help to
them adding wisdom to the equation and
that's proper generosity and that's the
only way our Family Foundation does it
we don't give to people or organizations
that don't abide by the things that we
teach that would be inconsistent why
would we do that
oh you're cold-hearted no I'm a good
steward I'm a good manager